our top story in London huge rises in
night price stabbed in Wembley daylight
to reintroduce stop in searches in gang
hotspots we are in an area where there
is poverty and deprivation our students
will experience gangs they can see
domestic violence it is it's it's
devastating I am Andrea Sakurako I am an
art and textiles teacher at Albertson
Community School good morning girls
namaste ladies good morning Kelly Mara
hola how are you you will agree with
that okay every single culture you can
think of exists here we have
approximately 35 different languages
being spoken in our school we have 85%
of our students who have got English as
an additional language this provides
challenges sorry I love this look I'm
really like from this work I teach art
and textiles and they are powerful
subjects that helps the students and
lock all of their language barriers own
final and prime school I had special
needs
I had speech problem she said looking at
worker that's your work don't let anyone
tell you what to do do what you love
which is that the hero thing truly is
wow that's amazing I love this it
doesn't matter if you can't speak
English we are able to help them achieve
and develop skills and confidence
hi I don't know where she gets like this
energy but it's been muscle as it's
endless I don't know how she does it
I absolutely love what I do I can't
imagine having any other job they're my
kids I am I'm a mom to about a 1400
students and Joe really is an absolutely
remarkable teacher there's a fantastic
job in the classroom but not just that
she will go the extra mile outside of
school of helping students in the
streets on the way home with the
community she'll do whatever she can to
help the aim now here is to get them
safely on the bus calmly on the bus
there is a gang culture outside of our
school gates have a good evening girls
bye love to see you see tomorrow it's
going on hi love have a nice evening
word individuals just recruiting
students - or young people to go into
their gangs Chris do you know those
well I became the chicken shop I've just
seen some unfamiliar toys that I've I
don't know a bit dodgy perhaps just
making sure that not after all with our
students you can't let that come through
the school gates we have to make sure
that we are protecting our students at
all costs that's that but you might
don't feel your instruction that good
girl I've introduced a boxing club this
is an opportunity for students just to
channel some of that theme in a safe way
in a controlled way which will hopefully
prevent them from ruining outside of
school enables them to have a great time
really getting physical growing their
self-esteem growing their confidence
this also helps them from not being out
in the streets
[Music]
you
[Music]
building relationships with your
students is absolute key Andrea's
greatest forte is helping teachers to
move on developing teachers that they're
better practitioners in the classroom
and that has the the knock-on effect of
making everybody more successful in the
school teaching is a really difficult
job I lead on professional development
to grow the talent of the future to help
teachers improve their skills
this is such an incredible award which
I'm proud of and this means that our
school has been recognized for having
the top quality professional development
for our staff
I think our faith in everyone being able
to achieve the best they can you know
she always says that about any
individual they can always achieve the
best you can believe her you go okay
okay I could do it I could do it you
can't help but get that immunity grab on
to that enthusiasm that she has and it
drives you forward as well
my calling in life is to make sure that
every single child reaches their full
potential that I unlock that that I make
sure that whatever it is that they need
to achieve I make it happen for them she
would look after me like my mom would
look after me it doesn't matter where
they come from it doesn't matter who
they are she will push you to your full
potential no matter what
[Music]
I
some of these students in this room they
have got hard lives so for them to be
able to shine so bright like diamonds
it's just magical
[Applause]
[Music]